The Angular framework is made up
of several different components.
We'll be looking at how each of these
components interact with each other
as we work through this lesson.
But it's helpful to see roughly how
they all fit together before diving into
the specifics of each one.
The first thing we'll look
at is the module component.
Think of a module as a container that
stores the different parts of an app.
Like any framework,
Angular provides a templating system
that let's you format the HTML
structure of your application.
This is the view part of the NBC
framework architecture
that Angular follows.
The controller is where you set up
the initial state and logic for a view.
The scope is what binds the template
in the controller together.
When the user interacts with the
template and changes some of the data,
the scope watches for this change and
updates the controller.
On the flip side,
if the data changes in the controller
then the template is updated.
Directives are markers on a template
that tells the Angular HTML compiler
to attach special behavior
to a DOM element.
A service is closely
tied with controllers.
You would put view independent
logic in a service.
Then you can use that service
in many different controllers.
For example, a service could be used
to fetch and store a user object.
This one service could then be used
in multiple different controllers.
An Angular app doesn't need a router.
But the more complicated an app gets,
the more likely it is that you'll want
one to help manage
the application state.
Our router will watch the URL and load
the correct template and controller.
Let's take a look at how to add
Angular to an existing project.